c'est la météo qui décide du moment où
mathieu la chapelle va sortir bravé la
tempête ils pourchassent le guéry zélé
le verglas comme d'autres scientifiques
court après les tornades c'est un
radiomètre c'est un instrument qu'est
l'université du colorado est venu
installer ce soir c'est la dernière fois
que les instruments prêté par
environnement canada vont se tourner
vers le ciel de sorel-tracy
pendant six semaines ce doctorant au
département des sciences de l'atmosphère
de l'uqam à scruter les précipitations
quand elle flirtait avec le zéro degré
celsius non s'intéresse principalement
au cocktail météo donc vraiment les
situations on n'est pas sûrs du type de
prestations dont un enregistrement mais
souvent en pluie c'est un travail
d'équipé avec quatre citations comme
celle-ci répartis dans la vallée du
saint laurent battles façon amf en fait
qu'on va envoyer un ballon par station
tout en même temps c'est par le l'avion
au port vraiment se représenter en 3d la
température
adaptée
dès que les précipitations mixte
s'annonce on lance les ballons sondes
toutes les deux heures
si les ballons peuvent atteindre 20
kilomètres d'altitude c'est ce qui se
passe sous les couches d'air chaud à
trois ou quatre kilomètres qui importe
puis avec l'avion de recherche ça nous
dit qu'est ce qui leur ôte une tête
qu'est ce qui tombe à travers
l'atmosphère qui fait qu'on a par
exemple de la neige du verglas ou du
grésil l'étude américaine ou entre mix
couvre la vallée du lac champlain et il
la vallée du saint laurent cette
dernière étant un point stratégique de
comme un petit bonus là on est un petit
peu plus de valeur que les autres
endroits les données qui seront
maintenant analyser auront des retombées
bien concrète par exemple de meilleures
prévisions pour guider les travaux
publics dans leurs choix d'équipements
ça prend juste quelque chose qui fait
basculer la température au dessus de
zéro ou en dessous de zéro pour faire
une grosse différence puis on y passe
jeu ça
aux trottoirs les grands parents de
mathieu la chapelle ont accepté
d'héberger et d'alimenter les
instruments en électricité tels
m'intéresse c'est un petit peu tout le
monde que les voisins me pose un petit
peu de questions aussi
dopé ballon
les ballons curieux destin le petit
garçon qui était venu se réfugier ici en
1998 pendant la crise du verglas est
revenu pour quelques semaines la manche
et si vous utilisez la place en six
semaines il y a eu dix épisodes de
précipitations mix de chercheurs sont
comblés
ici anne louise despatie radio-canada
sorel-tracy